out of all the ancient Hellenistic
schools of philosophy the most famous
today is undoubtedly the stoics or
stoicism there are incredibly successful
YouTube channels and podcasts dedicated
to stoicism a lot of you may have read
the meditations by Marcus Aurelius there
are books conferences and people who use
stoicism as a way to
perform better at their corporate job
Indeed the exposure that many people
will have had when it comes to the
stoics is a version that is let's say a
bit shallow where certain aspects of
stoic thought is used to for instance
optimize productivity or gain wealth or
worldly success it's a movement that has
today been dubbed broazism the word
stoic as in a person being stoic is
often used today to describe someone
that is emotionally distant right that
doesn't have any emotions doesn't feel
anything is simply driven by the
rational thinking and not by their
emotions and you know frankly a lot of
the depictions of stoicism or
understandings of stoicism that many
people have today would probably make
some of the actual ancient stoics turn
in their graves
but this is only a part of the story so
what is the full story what is stoicism
where does it come from and what are
some of its philosophical and maybe
religious teachings
[Music]
stoicism is a school of philosophy that
developed in ancient Greece during the
so-called Hellenistic age
indeed stoicism was probably the most
widespread and popular School of
philosophy in the Hellenic world right
up until the rise of neoplatonism in the
third and fourth centuries but would of
course continue to have an influence
even to this very day it was founded in
Athens that most Central of ancient
cities for philosophy its very name
stoicism comes from the Greek term stowa
poikile which means painted porch and
refers to a literal porch that stood
right next to the Agora or Marketplace
in Athens it was here in the middle of
the bustling City Life that the first
stoics would gather to purposely engage
with the public the founder of stoicism
is often said to be Zeno of kittium a
figure originally from Cyprus who is
said to have studied philosophy under
the famous cynic philosopher karates and
there are indeed some significant
similarities between stoicism and the
cynics
but Zeno is also said to have studied
with other philosophers and the school
that he started was unique and original
in very important ways while Zeno is
considered the founder the fundamental
features of the philosophy of course
developed over time with his successors
he was first succeeded by a guy called
cleanses and then by the figure
christipus who is one of the most
significant figures for the formation of
classic stoic doctrines and is often
considered the greatest of all the
stoics in history crisippus lived in
Athens just like the other stoic leaders
unlike some other Traditions that we
have discussed the stowa was actually a
literal School in the sense of a
connected group of people with a leader
and crisippus was one such significant
head of this school he is said to have
written an insane amount of works over
700 books in which he presented his
interpretations of Zeno's ideas in the
basics of stoicism it gives me no
pleasure to tell you that not a single
of these Works have survived we do know
of Christopher's ideas and significance
though through references and quotes in
other works and can thus get an idea of
his thought the importance of this guy
for historicism cannot be overstated he
made significant Innovations in all
kinds of philosophical Fields perhaps
above all in logic and we will have time
to get into some of these ideas soon now
stoicism is one of these so-called
Hellenistic schools of philosophy
alongside other major groups like these
Skeptics of the platonic Academy and the
epicureans as well as of course the
cynics peripatetics and others and they
would frequently engage in polemic and
debate with these other schools
especially these Skeptics who were their
kind of arch enemies and in order to
understand stoicism it's helpful to get
a grasp of this larger philosophical
environment
indeed one thing that unified all of
these schools was their reverence for
the figure of Socrates
the stoics the Skeptics the cynics the
epicureans they all claim to represent
the ideas of Socrates at least in some
sense
the problem was they all interpreted
what those ideas were differently we
know of Socrates and his activities
mainly from the discourses of Plato and
those who followed Plato and his Academy
the academics of course looked to
Socrates as a fundamental role model and
while the earliest Academy was concerned
with trying to figure out what the
actual doctrines of Plato were very
shortly thereafter there was a major
shift in Focus instead the academics
seemed to glean from the dialogues the
main theme of skepticism
Socrates or Plato wasn't representing an
actual Doctrine or doctrine is to be
elucidated but rather challenging
anyone's claim to absolute knowledge
thus the platonic Academy became the
school known as the Skeptics whose main
philosophical characteristic is pretty
much right in the name they believe that
we can't reach certainty or true
knowledge about anything at all in the
world although there can be different
levels of plausibility at least in some
schools or branches of skepticism this
is of course a very short and
generalizing presentation but that's the
gist of this school the epicureans a
School founded by the figure epicurus
was hedonistic in nature they believed
that what should be sought in life was
pleasure albeit in moderation
indeed another one of the features that
all these philosophies touch on or deal
with is the kind of goal in life
something called ataraxia
which means something like absence of
disturbance or trouble
perhaps Loosely translatable to
something like contentment
sometimes it's translated as happiness
but that doesn't quite do it justice
so how does one achieve this state of
ataraxia and connected to this what is
the nature of a good life what is it
that is good at all good being defined
here as something that is desirable for
its own sake
for the epicureans the answer was pretty
simple the highest good in life is
pleasure pleasure is the only thing that
is valuable in this world
since they were materialists this seemed
a pretty obvious conclusion
but it isn't Hedonism in the more crude
sense the ideas of epicurus are actually
a lot more nuanced than that He suggests
a kind of aesthetic lifestyle as the
best option where true pleasure is the
ataraxia or contentment that comes with
a moderate lifestyle and the pleasures
that result from it
the academic Skeptics had a different
idea to them no certain knowledge was
available to humans so we are to suspend
judgment of anything we know realize
that we know nothing for a certain and
that is only in this state of mind that
ataraxia is reached for Aristotle and
the peripatetics the highest good in
life is erudimonia something more close
to well-being or Living Well in general
so what's the position of the stoics on
this matter
they did not believe that the highest
human good was well-being or happiness
or health or pleasure or any of these
things indeed to the stoics all these
things were indifferent without any
intrinsic value
the only thing that is truly valuable
the only good in this world is virtue
nothing else can bring a person to
contentment or quote-unquote happiness
not wealth or physical health or not
power or pleasure only virtue but what
does this mean how is a stoic to
actually live his or her life
we're given a seemingly clear-cut answer
by the second scholar or leader of the
stoics cleanses when he says that the
goal of Life the Telos is quote Living
in agreement with nature
to live a life in accordance with nature
is a recurring theme in all of stoic
ethics but you might ask what does this
actually mean then we'll return to stoic
ethics soon but it might do as well to
get a sort of overview of the of the
philosophy in general first
so in stoicism philosophy is often
divided into three main categories or
parts logic physics and ethics it is the
ethical teachings of stoicism that have
become particularly famous today but the
other parts are also equally important
to understand in order to get a sort of
full picture of this school
to many logic is the basis from which
all philosophy must start this is sort
of jumping off point for all other
aspects of philosophy right today logic
might seem to many people like an
obvious thing things are logical because
they're logical right but in philosophy
logic is actually kind of science it's a
it's a way of studying examining the
nature of truth and how we can know what
is true logic was very important to the
stoics in some ways as a kind of
prerequisite for the other two
categories in one comparison philosophy
is seen as an egg
the shell is logic the egg white is
physics and the egg yolk is ethics
this hierarchy can vary for example
chrysippus seems to rather follow the
structure you know logic as a shell
ethics as right and physics as the the
yolk but logic is always the sort of
first or outer the shell in this analogy
right now I am not a logician so if I
actually attempted to do a deep dive
into stoic logic it would probably turn
out
not so great what I can do is briefly
mention that stoic logic is a very
significant thing in the history of
philosophy and the stoics developed
logic in a way that would become very
influential and in particular chrysippus
is strongly Associated and seen as the
sort of originator of a lot of stoic
logic crisis in fact is sometimes viewed
as one of the greatest logicians in all
of history he was truly a genius in many
many ways and this was one of them
throughout history however the logic of
Aristotle has been the most famous and
widely used at least up until the modern
period and the logic of Aristotle and
that of the stoics are different in some
fundamental ways
as a very brief summary Aristotle's
logic is a categorical one based on
syllogisms a classic syllogism will be
something like all a equal B and all b
equals c that must mean that all a also
equals c or to replace the letters with
actual words Socrates is a man all men
are mortal that must mean that Socrates
is mortal
stoic logic is instead based on
propositions and their relationship for
instance a classic stoic proposition if
it is day there is light but it is day
therefore it is light
chrysippus was again a very important
figure in this regard
what is it about these propositions that
make them true
some philosophers would argue that a
proposition is true as long as the
second part isn't as a matter of fact
false while the first one is true so for
example if I said if it is day then I am
great at explaining logic that would be
considered True by some philosophers
including Philo of Megara
because none of those two statements are
necessarily false although you could of
course argue about the second part
icipus didn't agree however he basically
held the idea that a proposition can
only be true if the opposite of the
consequence that is the second part
would falsify the first part you could
say if it is day then I am bad at
explaining logic and that wouldn't
change anything whether I am good or bad
at explaining logic has no bearing on
whether it is day
but if we take a proposition that would
be considered shoe according to
crisippers such as the already mentioned
classic if it is day there is light then
things are different
because if the second part isn't true if
it is dark for instance then the first
part can't be true if that is the case
then that must mean that it is night
rather than day
in other words if it is day there is
light is a true statement
precipice gives us five argument forms
the first of which is the one that we've
already given if it is day there is
light but it is day therefore there is
light the second argument form can
actually clarify the point we just made
about the relationship between truths in
part A and B
this form goes if it is day there is
light but there is not light therefore
it is not day
we're not going to go through all the
argument forms or go deeper into this
topic now but these are the basic
characteristics of stoic and the
chrysippon logic which does differs in
some significant ways from Aristotelian
logic
needless to say the stoics considered
logic to be very important for
philosophy and in some ways as a kind of
starting point or prerequisite to go
into the other two categories physics
and ethics
the physics of this school is really
interesting
first of all there is no metaphysics in
stoicism
this is because there is literally
nothing Beyond physics to contemplate
still works in other words are
materialists they hold that everything
that exists are bodies or matter
even the human soul and God are
ultimately material physical things
there is no immaterial first cause like
an Aristotle immaterial Souls like in
platonism and certainly no world of
forms
at the same time though they also posit
that there is a kind of active
intelligent principle that rules the
universe the universe in other words is
kind of divided into two aspects an
active aspect and a passive aspect
matter sometimes called Prime matter is
the passive principle in the world but
there's an active one too
the world is ordered according to reason
and intelligence by a force that they
call the logos
with us once again encounter that word
which is often translated as word such
as in the Gospel of John where quotes in
the beginning was the word and the Word
was with God and the Word was God
the word logos means a whole lot more
than just our concept of word though
it's very difficult to translate but
among other things it encapsulates a
kind of principle of reason
logos as reason orders things it's a
faculty of human reason but also a more
kind of universal principle of reason
especially in stoicism where the logos
is the governing intelligence that
orders the whole Cosmos and is
identified with God or Zeus indeed there
are some sections of stoic writings that
are quite Pious and surprisingly
devotional in nature
quote most glorious of Immortals Mighty
God invoked by many a name O Sovereign
king of universal nature piloting this
world in harmony with law all hail
this pantheistic God of the stoics is
identified with nature itself it isn't
something that stands apart from nature
in the world but permeates all of it in
some way it is as we said the active
aspect of the world which is part of all
things
but remember the stoics are materialists
so this God is not something immaterial
present in the world but also somehow a
physical thing indeed it is also often
called by the term panuma which is often
translated as breath or fiery breath
God is a kind of fire not literally of
course but in the sense of being a very
subtle kind of matter similar to fire or
breath
it is physical but somehow permeates all
things being identical to Nature itself
all these terms are often used
interchangeably by the stoics god nature
logos the whole penuma to denote the
same concept this monistic or
pantheistic idea of God as
some kind of unity that that is that is
Unity that permeates all things
explaining the view of chrysippus
Alexander of aphrodisias wrote that he
quote assumes the whole of substance is
Unified by a certain panuma which
extends throughout it and by means of
which it is held together and remains
together and by which the whole is in
sympathy with itself
a fundamentally monistic worldview in
other words
this Divine principle governs all things
a pantheistic god that is reason itself
thus nature is perfectly unreasonably
ordered everything happens according to
the will or Providence of this God or
logos and everything is thus preordained
this also leads to the characteristic
stoic idea of determinism which we will
talk about more later when we read the
stoic writings we find that they are
often concerned with this idea of how
God orders all things according to
perfect reason and that we are to
appreciate the Perfection of the world
or at least to see everything that
happens or changes as indifferent the
logos is after all identical to Nature
including our own nature
human beings are special in this case
because we are a creature that has a
rational mind
thus we are participating in the Divine
logos in a way we are quote doing God
simply by being creatures with Minds
this is why we see in the writings of
Marcus Aurelius for example that refers
to the divine within
God is within and without it is
everywhere it is nature itself and it
moves and changes according to the
reason of the logos which is also
identical to itself
and this is what it means to quote live
according to Nature to align oneself
with the way that nature works with the
Divine logos
and this of course has significant
ethical consequences
because of this physical Outlook the
whole universe can be said to be a
single thing Marcus Aurelius says in the
meditations quote
think always of the universe as one
living creature comprising one's
substance and one Soul how all is
absorbed into this one Consciousness how
a single impulse governs all its actions
how all things collaborate in all that
happens the very web and mesh of it all
this leads very naturally to another key
feature of stoic physics that would be
very influential for related
developments too which is the idea of
cosmic sympathy or sympathia this is
basically the notion that all things in
the universe are interconnected and
interdependent on each other
a speck of dust on some planet in a far
away solar system has a direct
connection with my thumb or with you or
with the trees outside
everything is connected in an almost
occult esoteric way because after all
everything is one thing
don't get me wrong this
interconnectedness is also somehow
physical to the stomachs just as God or
the pneuma is material
even though later figures such as the
neoplatonist would interpret these ideas
of sympathia and more metaphysical ways
to the stoics reality is an
interconnected web where all things are
connected to everything else which also
allows them to explain occult things
like divination and esoteric reading
which will also return to more later
while this idea of sympathia is often
traced to the historic thinker
posidonius and later thinkers in
particular and maybe partly as a result
of his patronizing Tendencies we can
find ideas that approximate it from
earlier periods of stoicism as well
indeed the strongly monistic worldview
that was part of the stowa since the
very beginning kind of necessitated this
in a way if everything is one thing and
God is identical to that all then
everything must be connected in some way
we even saw a possible example of this
in crisippus from that earlier quote
where he's said to have held that quote
the whole is in sympathy with itself
this idea of sympathia has been a core
feature of stoicism for most of history
but became perhaps most prominent during
what is often called The Middle stoa
With figures like posidonius and his
colleagues who are often said to have
implemented certain aspects of platonism
into the stoic world view it would later
be taken up by figures like platinus and
the neoplatonists as well as by the
writers of the Hermetic literature and
would become very influential throughout
history and esotericism mysticism and
philosophy generally but stoicism is of
course a comprehensive philosophy just
like all other ancient philosophies it
wasn't just about theorizing or
thinking about all these
questions on an intellectual plain or an
intellectual sense it was also about
actualizing these ideas in your life and
living life according to what what they
saw as as the true way of looking at the
world living a good life in other words
how was the stoic supposed to live or
Implement these ideas
and this is where we get into the topic
of stoic ethics indeed stoicism is
famous today primarily for its ethical
teachings or ethical ideas
uh maybe most people have encountered
stoicism through all these different uh
YouTube channels or podcasts or
Instagram posts or books maybe that talk
about stoicism but these sources often
primarily focus on first of all the
later stoics the Roman stoics and also
almost exclusively with ethical
teachings and ethical ideas how to live
your life how to be less anxious maybe
how to get up in the morning all these
kinds of of aspects and very rarely do
they deal with these other equally as
important aspects of stoic Doctrine like
um like logic and physics when we talk
about stoicism Scholars often divide it
into three distinct phases
first the early original historics in
Athens such as Xeno clienties and
crisippus this is where the school was
born and established its fundamental
doctrines
then there's the middle stowa or middle
stoicism including figures like panaceus
and posidonius which had their Center in
roads and among other things seem to
have implemented certain platonic ideas
into the system and lastly there is the
late stowa sometimes called Roman
stoicism which is basically when the
school migrated to the Roman Empire and
with Roman writers
many scholars also questioned the
simplistic division but it can be a
useful way to start getting an overview
of the history and different in these
different phases
and without a doubt it is the Roman
stoics and their ideas that the majority
of people are familiar with many of us
have read the famous works of Seneca the
discourses of Epictetus and of course
the meditations of Marcus Aurelius
all of these belong to the Roman stoa
which have some specific characteristics
among other things it is often said that
the Roman stoics have a particular Focus
precisely on ethics and none of this is
surprising and can be pretty easily
explained because indeed it is only the
Roman stoics whose writings have
survived to any significant degree
we don't have any full surviving works
by the early historics or even from the
middle stowa but we have plenty of stuff
from the Romans
so it's only natural that it is these
thinkers that are the most famous and
that the characteristic features of
their writings are the things that most
people associate with stoicism as a
whole even though of course chrysippus
deserves all the love that he can get so
what do the stoics teach in terms of
Ethics well we've already sort of dipped
our toes in it to some degree the quote
attributed to cleanses and sometimes to
Zeno that one's goal or Taylor should be
to live in accordance with nature is at
the core of the stoic life
we now know a bit more what that nature
is with all our knowledge that we've now
gained of stoic physics in particular we
can now sort of rephrase that sentence
to also say to live in accordance with
God or with Zeus to live in accordance
with reason or logos or even to live in
accordance with yourself since all of
these are seen as identical statements
the world is logos and is governed and
shaped by these logos
we as humans are also creatures of logos
or Reason and so for us to live in
agreement with the logos at large with
the whole as it is often called means to
align ourselves with the way nature
works almost to see and approach the
world from the perspective of that
Divine inside from the perspective of
Zeus or God as it were the way to
achieve this is to pursue the only truly
good in this world virtue the stoics
were unique compared to other schools in
that they considered all other good
things in life such as health wealth
reputation and such things as totally
indifferent
none of those things are either good or
bad and none of them in themselves at
least can lead to human happiness
and neither can they of course harm you
or lead to an unhappy life again in
themselves
Health in itself is neither good or bad
and can never lead to happiness for
instance only virtue can
and virtue to the stoics is identified
with knowledge especially knowledge of
things as they are according to the
logos of the universe
all forms of virtue are a can of
knowledge being a good or kind person
which is a virtue is a kind of knowledge
it's based on you knowing that it is
right to be good according to the reason
of the whole this may sound harsh or
weird to you why would you not consider
Health to be a good thing does this mean
that the stoics don't care if if they
are healthy or if they have food to eat
this is a good point and actually a
point that they were very much
criticized for by their opponents at the
time like the Skeptics
but
as you might expect the ideas of
historics aren't so crude while there
were some early stoics that went the
more extreme way crisippers and
basically everyone that followed
basically all the stoics instead held to
the idea that some indifference such as
health or moderate wealth are preferred
indifference it is preferred by a stoic
to be healthy rather than sick and they
will do their best to avoid getting ill
of course this is also in a way
according to Nature to not want to be
sick or that we all of course prefer to
have food on the table rather than to
starve but the stories also recognized
that none of these things although they
are preferred will ever bring happiness
in themselves and they thus remain
indifferent in that sense
it is a somewhat complicated Doctrine
and many of the ancient critics still
didn't buy it but that's the general
idea virtue and knowledge are the only
thing primarily to be sought a virtue
that focuses also primarily on yourself
rather than so so your own virtue so to
say rather than the opinion of others
those of you who have read the
meditations of Marcus Aurelius or the
discourses of Epictetus will recognize
many of these themes constantly they
will remind us to remember death that
death is quickly approaching and can
happen at any time
thus we are to focus on that which truly
matters living virtuously and not
getting caught up in things that
ultimately have no value and will
disappear
the stories encourage a moderate
lifestyle not necessarily for the
aesthetic one but one where worldly
pleasures are to be avoided or at least
seeking them out for their own sake is
to be avoided so to say quote wealth
consists not on having great possessions
but in having few wants
one often quoted principle of stoicism
as a kind of dichotomy of control there
are two kinds of things we can
experience in this life things we can
control and things we can't
if you're troubled by something that you
can control say for instance you are
sitting in a in an uncomfortable
position you can simply do something
about it you can change your position
or to take a less trivial example maybe
you have done something unkind to
someone and feel anxious about it in
that case you can perhaps apologize to
the person in question on the other hand
there are things in this life that you
cannot control the weather age or again
the fact that you're going to die
these things since we cannot control
them have no use getting upset about
because again there's nothing we can do
about them everything is ruled by the
Providence of God or Reason including
your approaching death and to get upset
about your own death is useless
a person with virtue who is aligned with
nature sees his death as just another
change as an inevitable part of the way
of nature or of God
to be upset about death is just as
irrational as to be upset about the
blooming of flowers in the spring or the
fact that a larva turns into a beautiful
butterfly it is the same change the same
nature and reason doing what it does and
is simply out of your control
Instead The Virtuous person accepts all
things that happen as part of the
universal reason as an expression of the
provenance of God gladly leaving this
world when it is his time
as Marcus Aurelius beautifully puts it
quote so one should pass through this
tiny fragment of time in tune with
nature and leave it gladly as an olive
might fall when ripe blessing the Earth
which boards and grateful to the tree
which gave it growth
and the same attitude should be used to
face all happenings in life especially
those that are out of your control not
to be phased by things that happen even
though they may be sad or unbeneficial
because they are after all simply the
workings of universal reason and the
interconnected Oneness of all things
everything is always precisely as it
should be
according to the stoics no external
thing can actually hurt us that is hurt
our soul obviously someone can stab you
with a spear and you will be physically
hurt but nothing external can truly
affect or hurt our true self or our soul
but ourselves when we are hurt by
external things or circumstances it is
not those things themselves that hurt us
but our perception or Judgment of those
things someone can say something really
mean to you but that doesn't really hurt
you only if you judge that mean thing as
hurtful or choose to look at it as such
then it hurts you but it is only your
judgment that does the damage this is
why we find in the stoic writings and
emphasis that we are not to care about
what other people think
Fame reputation praise or unconstructive
criticism it doesn't matter it has no
value it is again indifferent
the only thing we should focus on is our
own soul to make sure that we make
ourselves beautiful that we are kind
modest honest non-judgmental and all
other such virtues
going back to the idea of control it is
after all only ourselves that we can
control we cannot control what other
people think about us only how we act
and behave in life so all our effort
should go towards making sure we are
virtuous individuals
stoic ethics is often associated with
this kind of cold distant and detached
attitude and it is kind of true even
though it is a bit of a caricature the
stories do emphasize the kind of
Detachment in life to accept things as
they come since they are the workings of
God and then to be equally happy to let
them go once the time comes and perhaps
above all to let go of things that we
cannot control
Marcus Aurelius puts it in a brief but
very powerful statement quote accept
humbly let go easily
stoicisms does very much a philosophy of
self-control
one is to use one's reason that faculty
of oneself that is divine after all and
align it to the general reason or logos
of the whole and this also means
avoiding what the stocks call Passions
life is full of such passions or
emotions and they are often divided into
four General categories distress fear
lust and Delight
each of these of course have
subcategories of passions or emotions
that should be avoided or controlled
things like anger lust jealousy sadness
Envy Etc
to the stoics the passions are
essentially misunderstandings or false
attributions of value
they are the results of us falsely
concluding that something has goodness
or not when really everything but virtue
is as we said indifferent if we feel a
great sense of lust in general or for a
specific person this is because we have
falsely attributed value to achieving
the aim of our desire the pleasure of
sex
but this pleasure has no intrinsic value
instead the stoic practice is
self-control
he or she attains knowledge and virtue
by understanding the way the world works
the workings of the logos and his own
place in this reality
when they have achieved this knowledge
or virtue they no longer misidentify all
these passions with what is good instead
being able to see the the big picture so
to say we don't grieve at least not
incessantly when someone passes away
because we understand that this is
simply the workings of nature the will
and Providence of God simply another
change in a world that is constantly
undergoing change there is no difference
in value between a baby being born and
an old man dying it's all the same
change and it is only us that judge them
as either good or bad and suffer as a
result of that judgment when we have
self-control and conquer the passions we
can find true contentment ataraxia the
absence of Pain by living out virtue now
this shouldn't be seen as the stoics
being completely cold and emotionless
this is the caricature I mentioned
earlier they don't tell us to not feel
emotions but rather to approach them
from a reasoned perspective to
understand them properly with a clear
mind and thus experiencing them with
moderation you could say the stories
often wrote about feeling Joy or
pleasure but to not be sad when it
inevitably goes away that's the key part
this becomes especially potent when we
read the meditations of Marcus Aurelius
who was after all the emperor of Rome
during one of the heights of the
Empire's power reading his meditations
we find a person who is surrounded by
Pleasure in a certain sense although he
often rides from the kind of the
trenches of Germania in Wartime which
probably wasn't all that pleasurable but
he often talks about how one can be an
emperor to live in a palace and have
access to all these Pleasures maybe even
to enjoy them to some degree but still
to be a stoic philosopher and still to
remain a virtuous person it's all about
not letting those passions or Pleasures
control you not to attribute value or
goodness to these things in themselves
but still being able to live them
you accept Joy when it comes and you
equally accept sadness and pain when it
arrives but you don't hold on to any of
it when it goes away instead the
important part is to practice virtue to
be a good person
which according to Marcus involves
loving children caring for your people
being generous and having genuine
affection for people in your life not
some cold calculating emotionless robots
as many often imagine the stoics this is
a very important thing to point out
there is considerable nuance and depth
to these ethical ideas and we shouldn't
understand them in too simplistic of a
way
quote in your fits of anger have this
thought ready to mind that there is
nothing manly in being angry but a
gentle calm is more human and therefore
more virile it is the gentle who have
strength sinew and courage not the
indignant in complaining the closer to
control of emotion the closer to power
anger is as much a sign of weakness as
his pain
so self-control is obviously the
importance to focus on on
self-improvement and to take the
opportunity we have in this very
fleeting moment of our life to focus on
that which is actually important to be a
good person to improve ourselves to live
virtuously
but at the same time this might sound
strange or paradoxical when we consider
another key aspect of stoic thought
which is of course their determinism
since everything is controlled or
governed by God or pneuma or logos and
everything is that whole this also means
that everything is precisely as it
should be and couldn't have been any
other way
it also means that our lives as
individuals are decisions and actions
are also predetermined and beyond our
control
stoicism seems to say that we don't have
any free will at all
this is true but there is more going on
here the stoics indeed hold that
everything is determined by an
inevitable line of cause and effect
every cause necessitates its effect and
everything is predetermined in other
words everything is faded according to
fate not just the outcomes of things but
every detail about how things happen is
already determined by the chain of cause
and effect that have continued since the
beginning
everything we do is already determined
but the stoics still very much argue for
the importance of moral responsibility
and for the idea that our actions are
still up to us
how is this possible
well the stoics adopted a position that
has come to be called compatibilism
which is very simply put the idea that
the ideas of Free Will and determinism
are compatible with each other
this idea is still popular among
philosophers today and have of course
been understood in somewhat different
ways across history but historics argue
that our actions are indeed determined
to a certain degree certain causes
initiates how we will act but different
human beings will still act differently
based on their inner condition and state
of mind a certain person will respond to
a situation in a certain way because of
the way that she is because of her
character if we can still thus praise
her for it at least if it's a good
action right
our actions are still up to us because
we still choose how we act crisippers
used an interesting comparison to
explain this here we are told to imagine
someone pushing a cylinder down a slope
the cylinder Will Roll whereas if it was
some other object like a rock it will
behave in another way perhaps bouncing
around here and there or or maybe if you
try a cube it will not roll at all as
Cicero tells chrysippus's argument quote
as a person who has pushed a roller
forward has given it a beginning of
motion but is not given it the capacity
to roll so a sense presentation when it
impinges on the will it is true
impresses and as it were seals its
appearance on the mind but the active
Ascent will be in our power and as we
said in the case of the roller although
given a push from without as to the rest
will move by its own force and nature
the way we react to a cause is therefore
still up to us
this honesty perhaps isn't the best
argument though it still seems like the
shape of the cylinder or the way that it
rolls is still sort of predetermined by
or by its shape for example this is it
doesn't really
um
it doesn't solve the the the problem of
having both Freewheel or having things
being up to us and the strong
determinism the point here is that the
inner ASP or the inner nature the nature
of the cylinder is what makes it roll a
certain way even though there was a
cause that sort of initiated its
movement to begin with the scholar
Dorothea Frida gives another analogy
where we imagine someone offering a
bribe to a certain person that person
can choose to accept or deny the bribe
and his decision will be determined by
what kind of person he is his inner
nature so to say in other words it's
still up to him whether or not to accept
the bribe but he wouldn't have done
either without the initiating cause of
that other person offering the bribe to
begin with she goes on quotes that there
is a regular pattern of behavior does
not diminish our responsibility
it just brings out a fact that we have
come to terms with anyway that we are
preconditioned by our personality
this does not rule out the possibility
of improvement experience can affect the
inner conditions of an individual in
such a way that he or she learns to
avoid hastiness in his or her reactions
to immediate Impressions therefore
societies reprimands and rewards are not
futile there may be a lasting effect on
a person's inner nature so the stoics
through this compatibilism can uphold
both determinism and moral
responsibility and self-improvement
although this compatibilism has been
criticized and questioned by their
critics across history too these are
thus some of the key characteristics of
the histoic school of philosophy we are
focused on its three main categories or
aspects logic physics and ethics and in
all of these ways and through these
categories this will of course very
influential and very very important for
the history of philosophy but another
area in which these topics have been
very influential and one that may be
surprising to some especially given the
fact that they were materialists and
associated with this very strong
rationalism is that they have been very
influential also in the field of
esotericism and in esoteric hermeneutics
in particular have you ever encountered
day Mystic or philosopher who will read
or study a text like the Bible or the
Quran or maybe like the old classic
epics of Homer for instance and argue
that what is said on the surface of the
text isn't the actual true meaning of
the text or at least that the text has
different levels of meanings and hidden
meanings and all this stuff I'm sure
you've encountered this before
especially if you follow this Channel
and this is what it's often referred to
as esoteric hermeneutics or esoteric
interpretation
this is like again many philosophers in
history are associated with this kind of
attitude and this kind of reading of
scripture and perhaps surprisingly this
whole thing kind of starts with the
stoics if you remember the stoics
consider everything to be connected the
whole universe is essentially one thing
in which there is a sympathy between all
different parts
this also means that everything is
determined in a way there is a necessary
causal chain of events
because of this a sage who knows where
to look can read the world so to say
this is in fact how things like
divination Works which the stoics
definitely believed in
we can read the world around us to
predict things in the future things like
the stars or other natural phenomena are
like signs that point to a certain thing
or a certain outcome
and the same can be said about text
the active part of the world is the
logos and everything is and is
determined by that logos this means that
this logos or truth expresses itself in
different ways
there is in other words a perennial
truth expressed by the logos throughout
history a stoic truth of course but
sometimes hidden in obscure language
the stoics are some of the first
thinkers on record to take the old myths
about the gods especially in texts by by
Homer and hisid and read them
esoterically they believe that the text
says one thing on the surface but really
means something else on a deeper level
the stories about the gods and all their
escapades actually reveal something
deeper about the universe and of course
about stoic doctrine that perennial
truth that we talked about and a true
Sage can read text like that and extract
the true meanings from the surface
sentences
this kind of idea and reading of text
would of course become incredibly
influential for example with figures
like Philo of Alexandria in the First
Century A.D we see philosophers start to
apply similar techniques to the Bible
which put a far-reaching consequences
for not only Judaism but the very
formation of religions like Christianity
and Islam in other words stoicism has
been an incredibly important
philosophical School
it was as we said probably the most
widespread and most popular School in
the Hellenistic age until around the
time that neoplatonism arrived and it
basically disappeared pretty quickly
thereafter
but even so its ideas would survive in
different forms throughout history
titanus and the neoplatonist took many
of the historic's ideas and adapted them
into their system such as that of
sympathia for instance and even later
philosophers like Spinoza are often
argued to have been greatly influenced
by the stoics
and when you compare the two it becomes
pretty clear
Spinoza famously believed in a God that
was identified were identical with
nature
the whole term pantheism was basically
coined to explain his philosophy
there is only one substance and that
substance is God identical to the
concept of nature
and this is obviously very similar to
Historic ideas about God and nature
similarly Spinoza was a determinist just
like the stoics and arguably even a more
radical determinist than them if you
visit Spinoza's library in his home in
reinsburg and the Netherlands it isn't
very surprising that we find several
books by the stoic Seneca in his
collection even today stoicism is
relevant for people across the world not
just as an interesting ancient
philosophy but as having influenced
modern thought in huge ways for example
the form of therapy known as cognitive
behavioral therapy or CBT for short is
partly based on stoicism and the ideas
of figures like Epictetus his idea that
quote it's not things that upset us but
our judgments about them which we talked
about earlier forms a part of cbt's
approach to mental health which has
helped people worldwide deal with
anxiety and depression and continues to
do so in other words thoracism is
definitely a key aspect of the
intellectual Heritage of the world
since its Inception in Athens with
figures like Zeno clienties and
crisippus it has continued to play an
important role in the larger Western
World sometimes directly such as during
the Hellenistic age or today and other
times indirectly through its influence
on other schools like neoplatonism it is
a powerful school of thought that offers
perspectives on the world and our place
in it that were not only very useful to
the people of of ancient times but also
to millions of people worldwide today
hopefully this has been an equally
useful albeit of course very short
introduction to the historic School of
philosophy and its general
characteristics a school that helps us
better understand the context of ancient
philosophy and how it is developed over
the centuries and millennia
as always I would like to thank all my
patrons who support this channel
monetarily without you guys that would
not be able to do any of this I say this
every time but it's equally true every
time so as always I am eternally
grateful and humbled by your support and
of course I would appreciate if anyone
else wanted to become a patron it is the
best way to support this Channel and my
work of bringing you free educational
content on the world's different
religions history philosophy all kinds
of topics that are both interesting and
very useful for for our lives in
different ways so
I will leave links to all the patreon
stuff in the description you can also
leave of course a one-time donation to
the channel through PayPal and there
will be links to that in the description
and in the pin comment too
but of course thank you to everyone out
there who are watching commenting and
subscribing just engaging with these
videos it really is my pleasure to to
bring you all this wonderful history and
all these this wonderful
knowledge that I am so
passionate about myself and it's it's
really a wonderful thing to be able to
share it with you and the audience so
thank you again as always so much
and I will see you next time
[Music]